not listen to do anything but you feel
just about down that door played inside
Porter Babu group from the Wizards to
see it playing his part right now and
there he is getting a rebound for Porter
who goes off the glass score the field
goal at Auto with a chance for a
three-point put the heat me and Markieff
Morris also have three Wizards hit to
steal his river's quarterback two rivers
gives it up and they missed the shot
auto follows it up and in Lowry nice
pass for Valanciunas but it's taken away
by the strong arms of yon Mahinmi was
working on his strength in the offseason
great pass quarter
it's physicality to bump Valanciunas off
the ball and this is a nice give and go
in transition just the way you draw it
up great font nice find off of the auto
screen action the heat meat gets it back
out there reset now Porter will fire a
long free
[Applause]
walk quickly down court reporter and a
three
[Applause]
Porter with a chance for a four-point
play special the speed end-to-end and
then while playing at that speed the
ability to have perfect placement of a
pass to an open player in the corner and
look at that contest by Norman Powell if
that is not perfect placement buck
that's a block and that's why the
placement of passes is you need to do
and so if the team feels that being back
home and not traveling is going to get
him back on the court quicker I'm all
for that
terrific defensive play
Keith down Court that's it easy to do
great spins has it knocked away water
gets it back and score the field goal
will go to the line scrappy and Kelly
you bright with a nice attack has a
timely double by mo Harkless and Otto
Porter the recipient of the fortuitous
bound
here comes Lillard got a screen in the
backcourt Lillard drives raisin it's
blocked its blocked the Wizards hang off
for the wind blocked at the end
and watch this defensive play by Porter
that's the left hand the oft and my Auto
what a finish
[Applause]
[Music]
quarter Auto will let it fly for three
in it
yes bounces in Harris wall helps out and
stolen by Porter good defense by
Washington for Jeff Green any flushes
with the left hand auto drive goes all
the way for Mahinmi terrific pass and
Mahinmi cut into the glass scores
[Music]
Smith jr. kicks it out Washington has
the steel John Wall got a contact tipped
up and in by our dough
[Music]
finds the open man that's beautiful
basketball
porter drives store the field-goal auto
with a chance for a three-point play
look at a three-point shot a couple of
possessions ago in here under the duress
of the hit knack
three-point shot right before the buzzer
now Otto Porter finishes with some nice
passing food grace a Duran ski importer
not lived up to preseason expectations
and is not playing as well as they need
to play to win games in this league Otto
just swathes Gortat at the rim for what
you heard scott brooks say there that he
regrets some things that was said some
of the players regret what they were
saying is you could go one or two ways
now as this team finishes out this
season
you should try and model themselves
after in terms of how he works on both
ends of the floor like Brad broke and is
probing right there on the floor that
this group has Brad is able to get into
the paint
catches see ah come underwear with that
pass and then
Porter again this time the brides are
the Knights often under for the Youngs
Oh usually as a bench player but with
aunty Davis out of the lineup with that
hip strain he's got starter tonight Otto
Porter across the lane drops one in and
he's fouled on the play
take Cunningham McCoy Dell Demps did a
terrific job to get the acquisitions
that he did with Randall
elfrid Payton is well you know I feel
for the young man and I don't have any
knowledge of what is there not going on
with him or his bombs knocked away by
rivers and picked up by wall alle you've
come in for Porter and he scores
and Gentry once time Oh Porter has been
outstanding he leads all scorers with 27
Otto Porter now he shoots and hits a
three wall will try a three just missed
it rebound Porter to put it up and then
in the Wizards lead by two Auto drives
tough shot on the run wizards by 2 6-4
early again Porter with a deflection and
a knock away Beal stops what a shot
Satur and schemes Otto his long jumper
is good the Wizards have cut it to one
in this quarter they've made just 1 for
12
the Wizards are right back in it of 12
which he had the other night at Philly
10 points Porter drives for Thomas
beautiful pass and he cut for the basket
827 to play
beautiful pass inside for Keith sure was
excellent ball movement and great fine
by Opie passing in the quick decisions
so without wall the Wizards again go
with rivers and the smaller lineup and
that's locked at about their tenth
rebound advantage was the post again
this year score the field goal and a
blocking foul is called here there ain't
a no when that happens
[Applause]
it's a nice timing of the cut Decker
arisia pouch passport auto quarters Wars
and cuts the lead to two
[Applause]
Decker nice pass by Porter block by
Porter Decker the rebound Auto into the
paint lays it up and in
how about Otto Porter off the bench
Wizards come away with it it's Porter
Otto drives nice pass for Decker in the
finish Mahinmi inside picks it out for
Porter's long three yes Otto Porter and
Donovan takes time
what a display for this undermanned
wizard squad up 104 to 81 another
rebound by Philadelphia taken away by
Washington three on one
Porter drives in scores
fast break opportunity created by trevor
ariza excellent defense three-on-one
quick passing a Wilson Chandler Wizards
get him right back off the steal by
Porter Beal stops he fires for a long
three off the glass
little short rebound Saturn ski a reason
again for Porter to tie it does
[Applause]
water gettin from the rim here
shattering ski coming back in water
backhanded way it is good at the bow the
wrapkin
again run in transition good things will
happen as you get out and run especially
with the right hand
Porter down low
turns on Calderon score the field gold
and Otto will go to the line Lopez at
the five position you've got Middleton
you've got Brogdon all those guys can
make threes so the spacing is there for
Yanis to continue to attack saturon ski
attacks and he slaps it down auto stops
on the run but can't connect battling
for the rebound score the field goal and
a chance for a three-point play for Otto
Porter doesn't take long for him to pull
that trigger either as they get into the
lane for Otto Porter junior diving four
to shoot
31% water bar works oh that's beautiful
huh see he got fouled - poor Otto Porter
Jr the free cheese mounts in the house
couple of years with the Lakers couple
years now with the debts
Otto Porter I should say this is if he
can do this consistently which it's
shown in his marketed on him give it up
and the lane stripped away from Portis
[Applause]
[Applause]
easily better than well you could tell
you he's getting very frustrated with
Chris region
- here are they Jackson County farter
flipped in the corner there and gets the
block with that little bump before the
shot threw him off
marking it for local food stores calm
Markin
[Applause]
[Music]
Otto Porter Jr 2 4 5 2 3 tonight 10
points
nice set and the stuff on the back side
for cos nice setup by Otto Porter Judith
the long road to the table
Porter's step back they feed ATO
pump-fake into the corner RTD action Oh
Barry Switzer hold it a three here on
the court for point edge for the balls
tumbling into the trees Otto with the
steal
music cans for cuddling here's the
two-on-one Bradley
no gumbo for you forget soup no gumbo
who's had a two-possession Lee and his
let it slip through his hands
oh sorry marketing demonstrate please
please do that order
thanks the three give and go quarter
wraparound pass to the Hornets Gilmore
would be proud McDonagh [ __ ] good job I
Archie the a can already threw her away
Otto Porter the sagging finish this is
at point-blank range
there's good rotation my Otto Porter and
make him have to change that shot now in
the air now rather that down they tied
the game at 51 but now the holes look
like they have all the energy and
Indiana looks flat down a three ties the
game at 51
- 15 left Robin the inside his sores and
it's her time he's touched in the long
while Porter trying to get Redick on his
hip Redick did a nice job staying in
front cornered forces at all gets the
role that draws the whistle on rennet
Lynch's on JJ reddick he is 6 foot 8 so
he's just gonna try to do the same thing
Tobias Harris just did
Lakers Nuggets with LeBron going to pass
Michael Jordan on the all-time scoring
list as Porter gets it to drop plus the
foul Larkin in as size on Redick shot
much in the fourth great pass done
disorder pika
[Applause]
super one opportunity for Philadelphia
[Music]
nicety inside from Chicago Lopez will go
dribbles handoff Lance backing wheels
him in score pretty way seven straight
shots my Otto Porter in defense another
knock away turnover they get Zach on the
fly
[Music]
sporter big three they go underneath the
screen on
order kind of lingering a little bit
well right now both teams not shoot the
ball particularly well for of 11 for the
goes turnaround by Otto Porter Jr and
green boots who has called the timeout
he'll try to get back in this ballgame
an 11 point deficit like Sunday morning
him out of Porter the 14 shooting just 1
of 5 from behind the arc Porter goes to
work
sweeten it with that right hand
attacking Marvin Bagley the 20 year old
rookie what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content